2014's interstellar and falls in a
dystopian version of the year 2067
in which earth is rapidly becoming an
inhabitable thanks to climate change
a group of astronauts travel to a
wormhole near saturn in hopes of finding
a new home for humanity
former nasa pilot joseph cooper leads
the team of researchers on the mission
through the wormhole
the mission doesn't exactly go the way
they planned but don't worry this is a
christopher nolan movie
so you don't have to stress about
everything making perfect sense they
constructed this three-dimensional space
inside their five-dimensional reality to
allow you to understand it
well that ain't working cooper's
daughter murphy often called murph is
played by jessica chastain in adulthood
murph becomes a nasa scientist herself
as a story unfolds but at the beginning
of the film before cooper has taken off
on his mission she's still just a kid
since hollywood the aging software isn't
quite ready for prime time
the 10 year old version of murph is
played by another talented actress
mackenzie foy
young murph doesn't just dazzle with the
heartbreaking portrayal of a young girl
about to lose her father in act 1
she also makes the surprise return in
act 3. long after chastain has picked up
the character's mantle
by the time foy appeared in interstellar
she had already become somewhat
recognizable from her role in the final
two twilight films
breaking dawn part 1 and breaking dawn
part 2.
additionally she played cindy perrin in
the conjuring one of the kids living in
a haunted rhode island farmhouse but
what about since intercellar
while some child stars fizzle out in
their teen years foy is still shining
brightly
while she hasn't appeared in anything as
widely recognizable as interstellar
foy's acting credits since the 2014 film
include a couple lead roles
in 2018 foy landed the lead role of
princess clara in disney's the
nutcracker and the four realms
the high-profile fantasy treatment of
the classic tale was announced in march
2016
and foy joined that summer alongside
kieran knightley helen mirren and morgan
freeman
very accomplished company for the up and
comer unfortunately the nutcracker in
the four realms was a flop with both
critics and at the box office
the film's shortcomings shouldn't be
attributed to foy's performance however
as alison rosa flick direct pointed out
in her review mackenzie floyd does a
very good job as the smart and beautiful
clara
and offers a believable performance as
this iconic character
thank you that seems to be the consensus
a capable young actress in an otherwise
mishandled film
as a result foy moved onward and upward
from the project even appearing in yet
another disney film just two years after
the nutcracker's debut a modern
retelling of black beauty
the classic 1877 novel about a girl in
her horse by english author anna sewell
has been part of pop culture for decades
it's been adapted for film eight times
and twice rendered into episodic formats
for british tv
the most recent attempt at a feature
length treatment found mckenzie foy in
the lead role of joe green
disney updates the story a smidge to the
present day despite the time
displacement
many of the important details from
sewol's novel are still present
joe is still a young girl who forms a
close bond with narrator
and titular black beauty in this version
characterized as a wild mustang though
foy claims top human billing
beauty is really the star of this
adaptation and to search the horse as a
properly famous actor giving voice to
its equine narration
kate winslet i knew that if joe could
feel the wind in her mane
it would help her to heal the film was
supposed to have a theatrical release in
2020 but the kobit 19 pandemic put a
damper on those plants and black beauty
ended up going straight to disney plus
where it's currently streaming critics
were a little kinder to black beauty
than they were to foy's prior disney
adventure the nutcracker in the four
realms
the equine escapade earned a 48 critical
consensus on rotten tomatoes with one
critic summing it up as quote
mostly pleasing that might not be a
clear-cut winnie but it's far from a nay
mackenzie foy isn't going anywhere
anytime soon and you'll no doubt see her
on the big screen again before you know
it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one